-Here's how this works.
It's like a reverse interview.
We're going to take turns
reading a fact about ourselves
It might be true --
it might be a lie.
The other players get to
ask you questions,
and then they have to come t
a unanimous decision --
truth or lie.
Scarlett, you'll go first.
Mayor Pete, which envelope
should she open?
1 or 2?
-I didn't follow
any of those directions,
but I'm going to wing it.
-I'm gonna say number 2.
-Number 2.
-Mm-hmm.
-I should open this.
-Yep. And then you read it
-I'm going to read it to you
-And then we get to grill yo
until we come up with
a unanimous decision.
-Oh. I got stung by
a jellyfish on my face
while swimming
off the coast of Italy.
-On your face?
What year was this?
-This was 2009.
-Which coast?
-I was off the coast of Sicily
-What kind of swimming stroke?
-Um...
I was swimming.
I was just doing --
Yeah, I was doing that.
-Breaststroke?
-Yeah, the breaststroke.
-What color was the jellyfish?
-What color was it?
-Yeah. Answer him!
What color was the jellyfish?!
Where did it sting you, exactly?
-It was clear.
I got stung on my face.
-Alright, can I ask --
-I got stung right here.
Right here.
-Alright. Can I ask a question
You know what
you're supposed to do
when a jellyfish stings you?
-What?
-Do you know what
you're supposed to do
when a jellyfish stings you?
You know that.
Did you follow protocol?
-You want to know whether
somebody [bleep] on my face?
-No, I did not -- No, no.
No. I said go to the doctor.
Go to a doctor is what I meant
What are you talking about
What are -- Is that where
your mind went?
-I did not go --
I did not go to a doctor.
-You did not.
Did it swell up?
-Is that what
you're supposed to do?
Go to a doctor when you
get a jellyfish sting?
-Absolutely.
-Okay, yeah, fine.
-First thing
you're supposed to do.
-Right.
-In Italy, an Italian doctor
Alright. We're out of time
Did she get stung by a jellyfish
in the face while swimming
I feel like she's fun.
She's also a really good actor
-I'm skeptical on if it
got her on the face.
Then she would have seen it.
I think she ought to know what
color it is, right?
-Yeah, that's true. Interesting.
-Well, spit it out.
[ Drumroll ]
-No, actually, I believe her
-Yeah, I think --
Yeah, we think it did happen
-It happened.
-Hey! We're good!
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Where was it?
Well, how did you react?
-What? How did I react?
-Yeah.
-I was like, "Aah!"
And then I just had this
enormous -- I mean, it looked --
It was, like, "Goonies" bad.
-Oh, my God. "Goonies" bad
Alright.
Good. I'm glad we got this
It is my turn. Here we go.
Which envelope
should I open, Scarlett?
-Um...
-1 or 2?
-Number 1. Number 1.
I should have probably -- Well
you asked me, right?
-Yeah, yeah.
-We're so polite.
We're Democrats. Okay.
-I once gave the
Heimlich maneuver to
Jerry Seinfeld
at a wine tasting.
♪♪♪♪
-What was he choking on?
-Yeah.
-I think it was meat.
A meat of some sort,
like a salami.
-Hmm.
-Mm-hmm.
-What city was this in?
-This was in The Hamptons.
-Were you at a party?
-No, it was a wine --
It was, like, a vineyard thing
I went with his wife
and my wife.
-Which vineyard was it?
-Wolffer.
-Who?
-I think it was
called Wolffer or something.
-Yeah, yeah. You think so?
-Yeah.
-Huh.
-Wolffer...Vandelay. No?
-No, it wasn't
Vandelay Industries.
It was Wolffer.
-Okay.
-Wolffer Estates.
They had a wine-event thing.
-Who else was at this --
-His wife, Jessica,
and my wife, Nancy.
We had to go for, like, a --
It was, like,
a charity event thing.
-What was the charity?
-Jessica's charity --
baby buggies or something.
-You gave him the full
Heimlich maneuver?
-I did, because I didn't kno
what to do.
-Where did you learn
the Heimlich?
-Posters.
♪♪♪♪
-I'm not sure.
This seems a little fishy to me.
-They were both at --
I feel like this whole thing -
it was an event,
but then they were standing --
-And out of all people who could
have taken the initiative.
-Yeah, it was you?
-Yeah.
-That's the hole in my story
Then yes.
I saved Jerry Seinfeld's life.
-I don't think so.
I don't believe this.
I'm saying no.
-I'm with you. It's a lie.
[ Drumroll ]
-It is a lie.
-Oh, look at that.
Alright. Well done.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-I had too many holes
in the story?
I thought, "What if I did?
Jerry would kill me
if I touched him ever.
Alright, here we go.
Mayor Pete, now it's your turn
I will choose the envelope
Is it 1 or 2?
You were kind of quick
to grab number 2,
so I'm going to go with
number 1.
-Oh, alright.
On the campaign trail,
I once ate an ice-cream sundae
made entirely out of pork.
♪♪♪♪
-Is this -- Alright, so,
when was this?
How recently?
-It was years ago,
campaigning in Indiana.
County fair.
-County fair.
They always make you do thos
corn dogs and all that stuff
-How many bites did you take
-I ate about half of it.
It was actually pretty good.
-You ate half of it?
-You ate of the --
-Oh, wait.
That sounds fishy to begin with.
-Wait. What did look like?
Describe what it looked like
-So, you know those, like,
Dairy Queen
parfaits that they make?
-Sure.
-You know, like, the...
So, instead of the fudge
is barbecue sauce.
And instead of the ice cream
is mashed potatoes.
And then instead of
the peanuts, pork.
-That sounds pretty good.
What did you wash it down with
-Root beer.
-Huh.
-And were there, like,
photographers around, like
making you take --
-No, there's no
photographic record.
-You did this out of
the goodness of your heart
-Well, I was campaigning.
You want to eat the local --
You want to impress the locals
-This was a local thing?
-Yeah, where were you again?
You were at --
-Yeah.
-LaPorte County, Indiana.
-LaPork?
-LaPorte County.
-LaPork county. Yeah.
Who was with you?
Who could have stopped this?
-LaPorte County Lions Club
maybe?
Democrats?
-The Lions Club was there?
Alright.
-You washed it down with
a root beer?
Is that your favorite soda
-No.
-Huh.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-What's your favorite soda
-Diet Coke.
-That's sussy right there.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah.
So, why was the root beer there?
Root beer appears more --
-Because it was nearby.
-Alright.
But you weren't choking.
It was all good.
Mashed potatoes.
♪♪♪♪
-This is bizarre. I don't know
-I don't think -- I don't know
-Well, when you're campaigning
you have to do
all this stuff that you don't --
-He did come up with that
recipe pretty fast.
If he had just --
-Well, he had all day to prepare
this lie, but...
-I don't know.
-No, I think you have to d
those things.
I think -- I don't know.
I think you ate it
and you enjoyed it.
-Oh, he's a politician!
I can't tell!
-They're the best!
The politician and an actor.
Oh, my gosh.
-I think he maybe ate it.
-I think he did.
I think he's telling the truth
-You ate it.
-I think we --
-You're telling the truth.
-Final answer?
-Yes.
-Yes. You ate it. You ate it
-Yes, I did.
-Oh, my gosh!
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Was it good?
-It was okay.
-It was pretty good.
-We did it.
-We're good.
Scarlett Johansson and Mayor
Pete Buttigieg, everybody.